Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local Crisis Centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode involves a crime against children. It may not be suitable for all listeners. Mrs Cross walked up the driveway of the East Salt Lake City home and rang the doorbell. She was counting on the job interview to go well and had dressed to impress. Her clothes and makeup were immaculate and her blonde wig was styled neatly.
我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的电话号码，请查看您应用中或我们网站上的本集节目说明。本集涉及针对儿童的犯罪，可能不适合所有听众。克罗斯太太走上盐湖城东部那所房子的车道，按响了门铃。她指望这次求职面试能顺利进行，并特意打扮了一番。她的衣服和妆容无可挑剔，金色的假发也梳理得整整齐齐。
For a difficult life, this was her chance at a new beginning. She wasn't about to blow it. Mrs Cross was responding to an advertisement in the local paper for a qualified nurses aid. The chosen candidate would provide round-the-clock care and companionship to Alice Sullivan, an elderly woman suffering from Parkinson's disease. Mrs Cross came with glowing references, a thorough knowledge of medications and a wealth of experience. Alice's son and daughter believed her to be the right person to assist their 86-year-old mother. They weren't wrong. After moving into a spare room in Alice Sullivan's home, Mrs Cross became the best live-in nurse the elderly woman ever had.
对于她那艰难的生活来说，这是她重新开始的机会。她绝不会搞砸。克罗斯太太是回应当地报纸上的一则招聘合格护工的广告。被选中的候选人将为患有帕金森病的年长女性爱丽丝·沙利文提供全天候的护理和陪伴。克罗斯太太带着极好的推荐信、扎实的药物知识和丰富的经验而来。爱丽丝的儿女认为她是照顾他们86岁母亲的最佳人选。他们没看错。搬进爱丽丝·沙利文家的一间空房后，克罗斯太太成了这位老妇人有史以来最好的住家护士。
Kind-hearted and caring, she ensured Alice never went without, even buying her clothing and gifts out of her own pay packet. Despite gentle probing, Mrs Cross never discussed her personal life or history. It was clear that she was deeply religious as she spent her spare time locked in her bedroom reading the Book of Mormon. In a rare moment of vulnerability on Christmas Day in 1992, she revealed that she had two sons, one of whom had died in a car accident. That day, she put expensive presents for Alice's granddaughters under the Christmas tree, explaining that she never had any daughters of her own to spoil. Mrs Cross was a loyal companion. She never took time off and told the
她心地善良、体贴入微，确保爱丽丝从不缺乏任何东西，甚至用自己的工资为她购买衣服和礼物。尽管爱丽丝曾委婉地打探，但克罗斯太太从未谈论过自己的个人生活或过往。很明显，她非常虔诚，因为她把空闲时间都锁在卧室里阅读《摩尔门经》。1992年圣诞节，在一次难得的流露真情时，她透露自己有两个儿子，其中一个死于车祸。那天，她在圣诞树下为爱丽丝的孙女们放了昂贵的礼物，解释说她自己从未有过女儿可以宠爱。克罗斯太太是一位忠诚的伙伴。她从不请假，并告诉
Sullivan's that she considered them family. Still, there was something odd about the woman. The Sullivan's couldn't shake the feeling that Mrs Cross was hiding something from them. So, nearly 30 years earlier, on July 6, 1964, Clifford Sanders and his 18-year-old wife, Theresa, stood facing one another in the lounge of their cramped, low-set home in the Californian city of Galt. Sitting in the corner of the room was the couple's 11-month-old son, Howard, playing with his toys. He was used to the shouting matches between his parents and had learned to keep to himself when they flared up. But this time was different. Minutes later, the doorbell rang at
沙利文一家，她把他们视为家人。然而，这个女人有些奇怪。沙利文一家无法摆脱一种感觉，那就是克罗斯太太在向他们隐瞒什么。那么，回到近30年前，1964年7月6日，克里福德·桑德斯和他18岁的妻子特蕾莎，站在加利福尼亚州加尔特市他们那狭窄、低矮的家中客厅里，面对面站着。房间角落里坐着这对夫妇11个月大的儿子霍华德，正在玩他的玩具。他已经习惯了父母之间的争吵，并学会了在争吵爆发时保持安静。但这次不同。几分钟后，门铃响了，在
Galt Deputy Sheriff Fred May's house, 200 feet down the road. Theresa Sanders was outside, cradling baby Howard. She tearfully explained that her husband had come at her with an old model hunting rifle, intending to beat her with the butt end. Theresa managed to pry the firearm away from her husband, causing it to discharge. Deputy May headed to the Sanders' house, while Theresa remained behind, clutching Howard and rocking back and forth. She asked over and over if Clifford was going to be okay, hoping that she had just grazed his hand. When Deputy May entered the Sanders' lounge, he spotted Clifford's lifeless body face up on the floor and surrounded by a pool of blood.
加尔特副警长弗雷德·梅的家，就在路下200英尺处。特蕾莎·桑德斯站在外面，怀里抱着婴儿霍华德。她含泪解释说，她丈夫拿着一把老式猎枪向她冲来，打算用枪托打她。特蕾莎设法从丈夫手中夺过了枪，导致枪支走火。梅副警长前往桑德斯家，而特蕾莎留在原地，抱着霍华德来回摇晃。她一遍又一遍地问克里福德会不会没事，希望自己只是擦伤了他的手。当梅副警长进入桑德斯的客厅时，他看到克里福德毫无生气的尸体面朝上躺在地板上，周围是一滩血迹。
A single bullet had shattered the 23-year-old's left wrist, entered his chest, and penetrated his heart. Authorities were well aware of the domestic situation in the Sanders' household. Two weeks earlier, Theresa had appeared at Deputy Sheriff May's house with bruises around her wrists and neck. Clifford had come home drunk, broken a window, and taken his anger out on his wife. Who was expecting their second child? Clifford had accused Theresa of infidelity before beating and choking her. Theresa opted not to press charges and tensions between the couple escalated until their final fatal confrontation. Theresa learned of her husband's fate en route to the local police station.
一颗子弹击碎了这位23岁年轻人的左手腕，进入他的胸部，并穿透了他的心脏。当局非常清楚桑德斯家中的家庭状况。两周前，特蕾莎曾出现在梅副警长的家中，手腕和脖子上有淤青。克里福德喝醉了酒回家，打碎了窗户，并将怒火发泄在妻子身上。当时她正怀着他们的第二个孩子。克里福德指责特蕾莎不忠，随后殴打并掐住了她。特蕾莎选择不追究刑事责任，夫妻间的紧张关系不断升级，直到他们最后那次致命的冲突。特蕾莎在前往当地警察局的途中得知了丈夫的死讯。
Her piercing, devastated screams were heard by street side onlookers as she was driven away. In September 1964, they're still pregnant Theresa Sanders faced trial for first-degree murder. Her lawyer spoke of the violence she had endured throughout her marriage, including being repeatedly punched, kicked, and burned with cigarettes. An acquaintance recalled the time Theresa had appeared on her doorstep needing a place to stay after escaping from her enraged husband. Even Clifford's sister didn't want Theresa to end up in prison, but acquitted so she could go home and take care of her children. On the stand, Theresa emotionally described how she had fought for her husband's rifle
当她被带走时，路边的旁观者听到了她那刺耳、绝望的尖叫声。1964年9月，依然怀着孕的特蕾莎·桑德斯因一级谋杀罪受审。她的律师讲述了她在整个婚姻期间所遭受的暴力，包括被反复殴打、踢踹以及用香烟烫伤。一位熟人回忆起特蕾莎在逃离愤怒的丈夫后，曾出现在她家门口寻求住处。甚至克里福德的妹妹也不希望特蕾莎入狱，而是希望她被判无罪，这样她就能回家照顾她的孩子们。在证人席上，特蕾莎情绪激动地描述了她是如何为了自己、儿子和未出生的孩子而争夺丈夫的猎枪。
in fear for herself, her son, and her unborn child. A court-appointed psychologist described her as an anxious, remorseful, and frightened woman who posed no danger to herself or anyone else. After nine days of proceedings, Theresa held her hands to her mouth and visibly trembled as the jury delivered their verdict. They ruled that Theresa had acted in self-defense and acquitted her of Clifford's murder. Theresa approached the jury in tears and thanked them while sharing a warm embrace with the female members. Her lawyer told reporters outside court that Theresa only had one thing to say, quote, all I want to do is go home and take care of my baby. In March 1965, Theresa gave birth to her deceased husband's child,
出于对自身、儿子和未出生孩子的恐惧。一位法院指定的心理学家将她描述为一个焦虑、悔恨且受惊的女人，对自己或他人不构成任何危险。经过九天的诉讼，当陪审团宣读裁决时，特蕾莎用手捂住嘴，明显地颤抖着。他们裁定特蕾莎是正当防卫，并判决她谋杀克里福德的罪名不成立。特蕾莎含泪走向陪审团并向他们致谢，同时与女性成员热情拥抱。她的律师在法庭外告诉记者，特蕾莎只有一句话要说，引用如下：“我只想回家照顾我的孩子。”1965年3月，特蕾莎生下了她已故丈夫的孩子，
a girl named Sheila Sanders. Not long after, she met and married 18-year-old Robert Noor. The couple went on to have three children in quick succession, a girl named Susan and two boys, William and Robert Jr. Theresa stayed at home to look after the five kids while her husband took up work with the Navy, which led him to being away for long periods of time. Then in June 1969, Theresa filed for divorce, revealing she had once again found herself in an abusive relationship. In her filings, she described the daily threats and acts of great physical violence that Robert Noor senior had committed against her. A judge granted Theresa the divorce on the grounds of extreme cruelty. She was awarded full custody
一个名叫希拉·桑德斯的女孩。不久之后，她遇到了18岁的罗伯特·诺尔并与之结婚。这对夫妇随后接连生下了三个孩子，一个名叫苏珊的女孩和两个男孩，威廉和罗伯特二世。特蕾莎留在家中照顾五个孩子，而她的丈夫则在海军工作，这导致他经常长时间不在家。1969年6月，特蕾莎提出离婚，透露她再次发现自己处于一段虐待关系中。在诉讼文件中，她描述了罗伯特·诺尔高级对她实施的日常威胁和严重的身体暴力行为。法官以极端残忍为由批准了特蕾莎的离婚请求。她获得了孩子的完全监护权，
of her children, with the judge citing her fitness as a sole parent as a reason for his decision. For the second time in her life, Theresa found herself without a husband. She was also pregnant again. In August 1970, 24-year-old Theresa welcomed another child into the world. The little girl resembled her mother from the minute she was born, so Theresa named her after herself, Theresa Noor, though she was more commonly known as Terry. Two weeks after her 25th birthday, Theresa married railway worker Ron Pulliam. Although Ron wasn't physically violent, Theresa took his pistol to a friend's house for safekeeping after he threatened to kill her. This third marriage was also short-lived.
法官在决定中提到了她作为单亲家长的胜任能力。特蕾莎一生中第二次发现自己没有了丈夫。她当时又怀孕了。1970年8月，24岁的特蕾莎迎来了另一个孩子。这个小女孩从出生起就长得很像她的母亲，所以特蕾莎以自己的名字为她命名，特蕾莎·诺尔，尽管她更常被称为特里。在25岁生日两周后，特蕾莎嫁给了铁路工人罗恩·普利亚姆。虽然罗恩没有身体暴力，但在他威胁要杀死她后，特蕾莎还是把他的手枪带到朋友家保管。这段第三次婚姻也同样短暂。
By 1972, Theresa went back to being a single mother. When her older children were in school, Theresa would take their younger siblings to diners and spoil them with ice cream sundaes. There were family outings to the drive-in theatre and long road trips into the Sierra Mountains. When money wasn't tight, Theresa showered her kids with gifts and designer clothes. She kept their home in Orangevale, California immaculate inside and out, and all of her children were always polite and well-mannered in public. It was approaching midnight on July 16, 1984, when a carload of people travelled down interstate 80 out of Sacramento City. The driver sat alone in the front of the vehicle, scanning the rolling
到1972年，特蕾莎又回到了单身母亲的状态。当大一点的孩子在学校时，特蕾莎会带他们年幼的弟弟妹妹去餐馆，用圣代冰淇淋宠坏他们。他们会有家庭出游去汽车影院，还有前往内华达山脉的长途公路旅行。当手头不紧时，特蕾莎会用礼物和名牌服装宠爱她的孩子们。她把他们在加利福尼亚州奥兰治维尔的家打理得里里外外一尘不染，所有的孩子在公共场合总是彬彬有礼、举止得体。1984年7月16日午夜临近时，一车人沿着80号州际公路驶离萨克拉门托市。司机独自坐在车前，扫描着挡风玻璃外起伏的
Californian landscape beyond the windshield. They eventually spotted a quiet, deserted spot within the Sierra Foothills, known as Squaw Creek. It was perfect. Nessled between two passengers in the back seat was a young woman. She was unconscious, and her hands and mouth were bound with duct tape. Once the car rolled to a stop, the woman was removed from the back of the car. She was laid on a blanket along with her possessions, clothing, a toothbrush, perfume, cutlery, and several pieces of expensive jewelry. A copy of the Jules Verne novel, 20,000 Leagues Under the Sea, and a romance novel were also placed with her, as was a packet of infant diapers, one of which was soiled. Gasoline was then poured over her body and belongings.
加州景观。他们最终在内华达山脉山麓发现了一个安静、荒凉的地方，被称为斯阔溪。这太完美了。后座两名乘客中间蜷缩着一名年轻女子。她失去了知觉，手和嘴被胶带封住。车停稳后，这名女子被从车后座移出。她被放在一条毯子上，随身物品、衣服、牙刷、香水、餐具和几件昂贵的首饰也放在一起。儒勒·凡尔纳的小说《海底两万里》和一本言情小说也被放在她身边，还有一包婴儿尿布，其中一片已经弄脏了。随后，汽油被浇在她的身体和物品上。
The driver told their two companions, I'm going to run back and start the car. You light a match, and you just drop it and run. Once the fire took hold, the others raced back to the car where the driver was waiting. If you ever tell anybody about this, they warned, you're going to be next. At around four the following morning, a passing motorist noticed the flames arising from Squaw Creek and contacted the local fire department. A sheriff's sergeant arrived in the area and observed the small fire from the highway. Thinking it had been caused by a lightening strike, he radioed dispatch saying it would likely burn itself out or could wait to be extinguished later that morning. The sergeant went on his way and gave it no further thought. An hour later,
司机告诉他们的两个同伴：“我要跑回去发动汽车。你们点燃火柴，扔下去就跑。”火势一旦蔓延，其他人便冲回司机正在等待的车里。他们警告说：“如果你把这件事告诉任何人，下一个就是你。”次日凌晨四点左右，一名路过的司机注意到斯阔溪燃起的火焰，并联系了当地消防部门。一名警长中士到达该地区，从高速公路上观察到了那团小火。他以为是雷击造成的，便通过无线电通知调度中心，说火可能会自行熄灭，或者可以等到那天晚些时候再扑灭。中士继续赶路，没再多想。一小时后，
a truck driver was heading down Highway 89 when a woman ran from the surrounding woods to flag down his vehicle. She too had observed the minor fire at Squaw Creek and being a local that was familiar with bushfires, she knew something wasn't right. The occurring smoke didn't smell like burning wood. The truck driver retrieved his fire extinguisher and escorted the woman to the fire's location. It was contained and easily snuffed out. As the smoke cleared, the woman examined the remains. It looks like a mannequin, she said. Squaw Creek was soon swarming with police. The charred remains in the burn pile didn't
一名卡车司机正沿着89号公路行驶，一名女子从周围的树林里跑出来拦下他的车。她也观察到了斯阔溪的小火，作为熟悉森林火灾的当地人，她知道有些不对劲。产生的烟雾闻起来不像木头燃烧的味道。卡车司机取出了灭火器，并护送这名女子前往火源处。火势得到了控制并被轻易扑灭。随着烟雾散去，那名女子检查了残骸。“看起来像个模特，”她说。斯阔溪很快就挤满了警察。燃烧堆里的焦尸并不
belong to a mannequin. It was the body of a blonde-haired, blue-eyed young woman wearing a bright yellow hooded sweater. Aged between 14 and 17, she was less than five feet tall and weighed about 115 pounds. She had sustained third-degree burns to 91% of her body, with the fire itself causing her death. Superficial stab wounds to her back and buttocks indicated that she had been tortured, though it was unclear when or how these injuries occurred. A one-of-a-kind antique wedding ring was secured around her finger. Although the area where the victim had been found was a notorious dumping ground for bodies, the brutality of her murder horrified detectives. They examined missing persons, dental and fingerprint records, but were unable to ascertain her identity. She was given
属于一个模特。那是一个金发碧眼、穿着亮黄色连帽衫的年轻女子的尸体。年龄在14到17岁之间，身高不到五英尺，体重约115磅。她全身91%的面积受到三度烧伤，火灾本身导致了她的死亡。背部和臀部的浅表刀伤表明她曾遭受折磨，尽管尚不清楚这些伤害发生的时间或方式。一枚独一无二的古董结婚戒指戴在她的手指上。尽管受害者被发现的地方是臭名昭著的抛尸地，但她谋杀案的残忍程度令侦探们感到震惊。他们检查了失踪人口、牙科和指纹记录，但无法确定她的身份。她被赋予了
the status of Jane Doe, a placeholder name used by authorities when the true name of a person is unknown. The local sheriff called Jane's murder one of the saddest and most vicious killings in recent history. A description of the items found at the crime scene was publicly released to help identification efforts. Most concerning were the infant diapers with detectives fearing that Jane Doe was the mother of a young child who might be in danger. Yet no one came forward having recognized any of her things. An artist's rendering of Jane depicting a smiling young woman with a chipped upper front tooth also failed to generate valuable leads. Eleven months passed and detectives were no closer to formally identifying Jane Doe or her killer. On June 24, 1985, the driver was
“简·多伊”（Jane Doe）的身份，这是当局在不知道某人真实姓名时使用的占位符名称。当地警长称简的谋杀案是近期历史上最悲惨、最恶毒的杀戮之一。犯罪现场发现物品的描述被公之于众，以帮助识别工作。最令人担忧的是婴儿尿布，侦探们担心简·多伊可能是一个年幼孩子的母亲，而那个孩子可能处于危险之中。然而，没有人站出来说认出了她的任何东西。一张描绘着简的艺术家渲染图，显示了一位带着缺损上门牙的微笑年轻女子，也未能产生有价值的线索。十一个月过去了，侦探们在正式确认简·多伊或她的杀手身份方面毫无进展。1985年6月24日，司机
once again behind the wheel traveling towards Squire Creek. Like last time, it was approaching midnight and they were joined by two accomplices. There was one notable difference. Their latest victim was already deceased, tucked away in a cardboard box in the trunk. It was all planned out. They weren't going to start a fire like they had previously as they didn't want the two crime scenes linked. The driver accidentally missed the turnoff to Squire Creek and decided to continue onwards looking for another suitable place. They eventually came to a stop just outside the town of Truckee on the California-Nevada state border. The two accomplices emerged from the back seat and collected a shovel each from the trunk. As they started digging nearby, a police car happened
再次坐在方向盘后，驶向斯阔溪。和上次一样，午夜临近，他们还有两名同伙随行。有一个显著的区别。他们最新的受害者已经死亡，被塞进后备箱的一个纸板箱里。一切都计划好了。他们不像以前那样放火，因为他们不想让两起犯罪现场联系起来。司机不小心错过了去斯阔溪的转弯处，决定继续前进寻找另一个合适的地方。他们最终在加利福尼亚州和内华达州边界的特拉基镇外停了下来。两名同伙从后座出来，每人从后备箱拿了一把铲子。当他们开始在附近挖掘时，一辆警车碰巧
to pull up behind them. They raced back to the car and hid the shovels, just as an officer approached carrying a flashlight. The car's three occupants were certain they had just been caught red-handed. The foul smell of decomposition emanated from the trunk and would no doubt raise suspicions that something was awry. The officer asked what they were doing. The group informed him that they had pulled over to urinate. He then circled the vehicle while shining his flashlight over it. Speaking directly to the driver, he ordered them to move along and get back on the highway. The officer had failed to notice the rancid smell, the shovels, or the killer before them. They returned to their patrol car and drove off. The near miss rattled the trio who reformulated
停在他们身后。他们冲回车里藏起铲子，就在这时，一名拿着手电筒的警察走了过来。车里的三个人确信他们刚刚被当场抓获。后备箱散发出腐烂的恶臭，毫无疑问会引起怀疑，认为有什么不对劲。警察问他们在做什么。这群人告诉他，他们停车是为了小便。他随后绕着车走了一圈，用手电筒照着车身。他直接对司机说话，命令他们离开并回到高速公路上。警察没有注意到那股腐臭味、铲子，也没有注意到眼前的杀手。他们回到巡逻车上开走了。这次险些被捕让三人感到不安，他们重新制定了
their plan. The driver headed south where they came across a deserted road near a lake in the middle of bushy mountain land. The group pulled over, retrieved their shovels, and wasted no time in digging a hole. The cardboard box was discovered the following morning at Martis Creek Campground by a caretaker clearing trash in the area. It was positioned in a clump of weeping willow trees by the lake. Curiosity got the better of the caretaker who tore off the silver duct tape that sealed the box. When he opened it, a human arm sprung out. The body of a young woman was tightly packed inside in the fetal position, naked aside from a pair of underwear and white socks.
他们的计划。司机向南行驶，在灌木丛生的山区湖泊附近发现了一条荒凉的道路。这群人停下车，取回铲子，毫不耽搁地挖了一个洞。第二天早上，马蒂斯溪露营地的一名管理员在清理该地区的垃圾时发现了那个纸板箱。它被放置在湖边的一丛垂柳中。好奇心战胜了管理员，他撕开了密封箱子的银色胶带。当他打开箱子时，一只人手弹了出来。一名年轻女子的尸体被紧紧地塞在里面，呈胎儿姿势，除了内衣和白袜子外赤身裸体。
She was approximately 20 years old, 5 foot 4 inches tall, 105 to 120 pounds, with brown hair. The level of decomposition made it impossible to determine much else, including facial features or a cause of death. Samples of the victim's teeth, hair, and skin were compared to records on file to no result. There were no missing person reports that could be linked to the victim either. She too was formally listed as a Jane Doe, though trucky locals knew her as the body in the cardboard box. The killer had gotten lucky. The same medical examiner who conducted this autopsy also carried out the one on the Jane Doe found burnt alive at Squire Creek almost a year prior. The differences between the two crime scenes ensured the examiner failed to determine a connection.
她大约20岁，身高5英尺4英寸，体重105到120磅，留着棕色头发。腐烂程度使得无法确定其他任何信息，包括面部特征或死因。受害者的牙齿、头发和皮肤样本与存档记录进行了比对，但没有结果。也没有任何失踪人口报告可以与受害者联系起来。她也被正式列为“简·多伊”，尽管特拉基当地人称她为“纸板箱里的尸体”。杀手很幸运。进行这次尸检的同一位法医也对近一年前在斯阔溪被活活烧死的简·多伊进行了尸检。两个犯罪现场之间的差异确保了法医未能确定两者之间的联系。
Just like the investigation into the first Jane Doe case, the latest inevitably went cold. 4 months later, on October 14, 1985, Gayle Smith arrived at a rest stop just outside of the city of Fort Worth in Texas. The 20-year-old had been given a ride there by her step-brother, but that's as far as he could take her. Gayle had a 340-mile journey ahead of her to visit her mother in the city of Amarillo. As she was short on funds, Gayle chose to do what she had done many times in the past – hitchhike to her destination. She preferred accepting rides from long-distance truckers as she had come to trust them the most. Gayle's step-brother watched from his car as Gayle approached a male trucker with red hair and blue eyes. After a brief conversation,
就像对第一个简·多伊案件的调查一样，最新的案件不可避免地陷入了僵局。4个月后，1985年10月14日，盖尔·史密斯抵达了德克萨斯州沃斯堡市外的一个休息站。这位20岁的女孩是由她的继兄载到那里的，但他只能送她到这儿。盖尔还有340英里的路程要走，去阿马里洛市探望她的母亲。由于资金短缺，盖尔选择做她过去多次做过的事情——搭便车前往目的地。她更喜欢接受长途卡车司机的搭乘，因为她最信任他们。盖尔的继兄在车里看着盖尔走向一名有着红头发和蓝眼睛的男性卡车司机。经过简短的交谈，
she hopped into the passenger seat of his cherry-red tractor trailer. Gayle failed to arrive at her mother's and was promptly reported missing, but her fate had already been sealed. The morning after Gayle had left the Fort Worth rest stop, her body was found poorly concealed in a thicket of bushland near the Canadian River, about 14 miles from Amarillo. Her hands were bound by duct tape, and she had been taped tightly into the fetal position. She had been hit over the head with a blunt object, raped, and then strangled to death with a man's necktie. Although Gayle's step-brother hadn't written down the license plate of the truck that Gayle
她跳上了他那辆樱桃红色牵引拖车的副驾驶座。盖尔没能到达她母亲那里，并立即被报告失踪，但她的命运早已注定。盖尔离开沃斯堡休息站后的第二天早上，她的尸体在距离阿马里洛约14英里的加拿大河附近的一片灌木丛中被发现，掩盖得很差。她的双手被胶带捆绑，并被紧紧地缠成胎儿姿势。她头部被钝器击中，遭到强奸，然后被一条男士领带勒死。虽然盖尔的继兄没有记下盖尔
had hitched her final ride in, he did recall the make of the vehicle as well as a description of its driver. Most importantly, he recalled two words emblazoned on the driver's side door. Jewitt Scott Jewitt Scott was a trucking firm based in Oklahoma. The company examined their records and provided the name of the only employee who had been in the Fort Worth area at the time Gayle Smith had gotten a ride. 42-year-old Benjamin Boyle, better known as Herbert, had a violent criminal history. Six years earlier in 1979, he tried to abduct a woman by forcing her into his car. Boyle pleaded guilty for attempted kidnap and was sentenced to five
搭乘最后一程的那辆卡车的车牌号，但他确实记得车辆的品牌以及司机的描述。最重要的是，他记得司机侧车门上印着的两个字：朱伊特·斯科特（Jewitt Scott）。朱伊特·斯科特是一家总部位于俄克拉荷马州的货运公司。该公司检查了他们的记录，并提供了在盖尔·史密斯搭车时唯一在沃斯堡地区的员工姓名。42岁的本杰明·博伊尔，更广为人知的名字是赫伯特，有着暴力的犯罪记录。六年前的1979年，他曾试图通过强迫一名女子上车来绑架她。博伊尔对企图绑架罪表示认罪，并被判处五年
years probation. At the time of Gayle Smith's murder, he was on the run from a rape that he had committed in Colorado. Boyle, who introduced himself as Mr Whipple to women he was attracted to, had secured a load earlier that morning and was headed to a town 60 miles north of Houston. Detective Sped down Highway 59 and caught up to Boyle's truck. Boyle admitted to giving Gayle Smith a ride but said he had dropped her off at a truck stop in Wichita Falls, 250 miles short of her destination. Yet, the case against Herbert Boyle was sealed almost immediately. His truck contained some of Gayle's possessions and her blood and hair were found in the vehicle's cab. Carpet fibres from the truck's interior matched those found on Gayle's remains.
缓刑。在盖尔·史密斯被谋杀时，他正因在科罗拉多州犯下的一起强奸案而潜逃。博伊尔向他感兴趣的女性介绍自己为“惠普尔先生”，他那天早上早些时候装载了货物，正前往休斯顿以北60英里处的一个城镇。侦探们沿着59号公路疾驰，追上了博伊尔的卡车。博伊尔承认载了盖尔·史密斯，但说他在威奇托福尔斯的一个卡车停靠站让她下了车，距离她的目的地还有250英里。然而，针对赫伯特·博伊尔的案件几乎立即就锁定了。他的卡车里装有盖尔的一些财物，在车辆驾驶室里发现了她的血迹和头发。卡车内部的地毯纤维与在盖尔遗体上发现的纤维相匹配。
Finally, Boyle's fingerprints were lifted from the duct tape used to restrain Gayle with the roll itself discovered in his truck. In early November 1985, Herbert Boyle was indicted for the aggravated sexual assault and capital murder of Gayle Smith. Given his criminal history and transient job, detectives reexamined other unsolved murders to see whether they could be linked to Boyle. One case that drew their attention involved a young woman known only as Jane Doe found buried in a cardboard box at Martis Creek Campground. Her murder bore striking similarities to that of Gayle Smith. Both women were found off a highway and near water. They were bound with silver duct tape, placed in the fetal position, and were discovered in a state of undress.
最后，博伊尔的指纹从用于束缚盖尔的胶带上提取出来，而胶带卷本身是在他的卡车里发现的。1985年11月初，赫伯特·博伊尔因严重性侵犯和谋杀盖尔·史密斯而被起诉。鉴于他的犯罪记录和流动性工作，侦探们重新审查了其他未破的谋杀案，看看是否能与博伊尔联系起来。其中一个引起他们注意的案件涉及一名仅被称为“简·多伊”的年轻女子，她被发现埋在马蒂斯溪露营地的一个纸板箱里。她的谋杀案与盖尔·史密斯的案件有着惊人的相似之处。两名女子都是在高速公路旁和水边被发现的。她们都被银色胶带捆绑，呈胎儿姿势，并被发现时处于衣不蔽体的状态。
By delving into Herbert Boyle's travel logbook, receipts and maps, it was discovered that he had been in the truckie area at the time of Jane Doe's murder. Additionally, a foreign fiber on Jane's body matched a blanket from Boyle's house in Oklahoma. There was also a rope fiber found at the crime scene that matched a length of rope in Boyle's truck. Herbert Boyle only faced trial for Gayle Smith's murder. In court, he was depicted as mean and unlikable with perverted sexual urges. His wife and daughter expressed their concerns that Boyle would harm them if he should be found not guilty. His daughter told the court, I'm very scared of the man right now and I have been for some time. After deliberating for 20 minutes, the jury found Boyle guilty of the rape, kidnapping,
通过深入研究赫伯特·博伊尔的旅行日志、收据和地图，发现他在简·多伊被谋杀时就在特拉基地区。此外，简尸体上的一根外来纤维与博伊尔在俄克拉荷马州家中的一条毯子相匹配。在犯罪现场还发现了一根绳子纤维，与博伊尔卡车里的一段绳子相匹配。赫伯特·博伊尔只因盖尔·史密斯的谋杀案受审。在法庭上，他被描述为一个卑鄙、令人讨厌且有变态性冲动的人。他的妻子和女儿表示担心，如果他被判无罪，博伊尔会伤害她们。他的女儿告诉法庭：“我现在非常害怕这个人，而且已经有一段时间了。”经过20分钟的审议，陪审团裁定博伊尔犯有强奸、绑架罪，
and murder of Gayle Smith. He was sentenced to death. Although the body in the cardboard box case never went to trial due to lack of evidence, authorities safely assumed that Herbert Boyle was responsible for her murder also. They were wrong. Nearly 20 years earlier, on July 6, 1964, 18-year-old Teresa Sanders watched as her husband Clifford moved around their house packing a suitcase. An exceedingly jealous woman, Teresa constantly accused Clifford of having an affair and had taken to controlling many facets of his life. She had imposed a strict curfew on him, drove him to and from work, and handled all of their finances. Clifford was afforded just 50 cents for lunch so he wouldn't be able to
以及谋杀盖尔·史密斯的罪名。他被判处死刑。虽然纸板箱里的尸体案因证据不足从未开庭审理，但当局有把握地认为赫伯特·博伊尔也应对她的谋杀负责。他们错了。近20年前，1964年7月6日，18岁的特蕾莎·桑德斯看着她的丈夫克里福德在屋里收拾行李。作为一个极其嫉妒的女人，特蕾莎不断指责克里福德有外遇，并开始控制他生活的许多方面。她对他实行了严格的宵禁，接送他上下班，并处理了他们所有的财务。克里福德每天只有50美分的午餐费，这样他就无法
meet other women at expensive restaurants. When it all became too much, Clifford would stay in hotels for days at a time. With his suitcase packed, Clifford headed for the door and took one last look at his pregnant wife and their 11-month-old son Howard. Minutes later, Teresa arrived at Deputy Sheriff Fred Mays House down the road. She claimed that Clifford had attempted to beat her with a rifle. While she confessed to shooting him, she claimed it was an accident, stating, I did not think it would do that much damage. I didn't think that old gun would hurt him that bad. Teresa said she had wrestled the weapon from her husband, causing it to discharge.
在昂贵的餐厅结识其他女性。当一切变得无法忍受时，克里福德会连续几天住在酒店里。行李收拾好后，克里福德走向门口，最后看了一眼他怀孕的妻子和他们11个月大的儿子霍华德。几分钟后，特蕾莎到达了路下副警长弗雷德·梅的家。她声称克里福德试图用步枪打她。虽然她承认开枪打死了他，但她声称这是一场意外，并说：“我没想到它会造成那么大的伤害。我没想到那把旧枪会把他伤得那么重。”特蕾莎说她从丈夫手中夺过了武器，导致它走火。
The rifle, which was kept in the couple's bedroom, was always loaded. However, the safety was also always on. This meant the user had to click the safety off, cock the hammer, take aim, and pull the trigger to fire off a shot. It was an elaborate manoeuvre, and Teresa's story didn't account for it. Nor did it account for how cumbersome the rifle was in length and shape. Due to its long barrel, there had to be some distance between the shooter and their target to ensure a hit. The fatal bullet that had penetrated Clifford's chest passed through his wrist first, meaning he had attempted to shield himself with his hand prior to being shot at. This implied that the gun was aimed at him before it was fired.
那把放在夫妻卧室里的步枪总是装满子弹的。然而，保险也总是开着的。这意味着使用者必须关掉保险、扳动击锤、瞄准并扣动扳机才能开火。这是一个复杂的动作，而特蕾莎的故事无法解释这一点。它也无法解释步枪在长度和形状上是多么笨重。由于枪管很长，射手和目标之间必须保持一定的距离才能确保命中。那颗穿透克里福德胸部的致命子弹先穿过了他的手腕，这意味着他在被射击前曾试图用手保护自己。这暗示枪在开火前就已经瞄准了他。
With many aspects of her story not adding up, Teresa Sanders was tried for her husband's murder. Clifford's sister did say in court that she wanted Teresa to be acquitted so she could look after her slain brother's children. However, she also added, I believe with all my heart that Teresa Sanders planned to kill my brother. She recalled a time when Teresa pointed out a bullet hole in the floor of her home while proudly admitting that she had tried to shoot Clifford, but missed. On another occasion, Teresa said that she would kill Clifford before any other woman could have him. The jury overlooked this information, instead viewing the petite, pretty, and heavily pregnant
由于她故事中的许多方面都对不上，特蕾莎·桑德斯因谋杀丈夫而受审。克里福德的妹妹确实在法庭上说，她希望特蕾莎被判无罪，这样她就能照顾她被杀害的哥哥的孩子。然而，她也补充说：“我全心全意地相信特蕾莎·桑德斯计划杀害我的哥哥。”她回忆起特蕾莎曾指着地板上的一个弹孔，自豪地承认她曾试图射杀克里福德，但没打中。在另一个场合，特蕾莎说她会在其他女人得到克里福德之前杀了他。陪审团忽略了这些信息，反而认为娇小、漂亮且怀有身孕的
Teresa as someone who wouldn't hurt a fly. As detailed in the book Whatever Mother Says by Wensley Clarkson, days after being acquitted of her husband's murder, Teresa visited the office of the prosecuting district attorney. She had one request, the rifle that had been used to kill Clifford. She wanted it back. Neither of Teresa's next two husbands, Robert Norcenia or Ronald Pulliam, met with foul play, but both marriages ended after Teresa's controlling nature became too much to bear. Following her second divorce in 1972, Teresa became somewhat of a religious fanatic, obsessively pouring over the Bible while constantly quoting scripture to her children.
特蕾莎是一个连苍蝇都不忍心伤害的人。正如温斯利·克拉克森在《无论母亲说什么》一书中所述，在被判谋杀丈夫无罪释放几天后，特蕾莎拜访了负责地区检察官的办公室。她有一个要求：那把用来杀害克里福德的步枪。她想把它要回来。特蕾莎接下来的两任丈夫，罗伯特·诺尔或罗纳德·普利亚姆，都没有遭遇不幸，但两段婚姻都在特蕾莎的控制欲变得无法忍受后结束了。1972年第二次离婚后，特蕾莎在某种程度上变成了一个宗教狂热分子，痴迷地研读《圣经》，同时不断向她的孩子们引用经文。
They quickly grew to be afraid of their mother. Ranging from three to ten years old, Teresa physically disciplined her children harshly over the smallest of incidents. She perceived any slight as an intentional act of defiance, like when they accidentally spilled crumbs of food. The abuse escalated as the children got older. Daily beatings or whippings were common. After extreme punishments, Teresa forced her children to take ice baths so their bruises wouldn't be noticed at school. Although she abused all her children, it was Teresa's daughters, Susan, Sheila, and Terry, who bore the brunt of their mother's fury.
他们很快就开始害怕他们的母亲。从三岁到十岁不等，特蕾莎因最小的事情对孩子们进行严厉的体罚。她将任何轻微的冒犯都视为故意的反抗行为，比如当他们不小心洒下食物碎屑时。随着孩子们长大，虐待行为升级了。日常的殴打或鞭打是家常便饭。在极端的惩罚之后，特蕾莎强迫孩子们洗冰水澡，这样他们在学校就不会被发现淤青。虽然她虐待所有的孩子，但特蕾莎的女儿们——苏珊、希拉和特里——承受了母亲愤怒的主要打击。
Chet Harris met Teresa in August 1976 after crossing paths with her in a bar. Chet was an editor for the Sacramento Union newspaper. At 59 years old, he was doubled Teresa's age. He was also an obese, five-time divorcee with a two-pack-a-day smoking habit and an addiction to pornography and alcohol. Still, he caught Teresa's eye and the pair married within three days of their first encounter. Chet made no attempt to hide the fact that he didn't like Teresa's children. They didn't like him much either. The only exception was Susan Noor, Teresa's third eldest. Extremely intelligent and a voracious reader, 10-year-old Susan formed a special bond with Chet, who engaged her in conversations about
切特·哈里斯在1976年8月在一家酒吧与特蕾莎偶遇后认识了她。切特是《萨克拉门托联合报》的编辑。59岁的他比特蕾莎大一倍。他还是一个肥胖、离过五次婚、每天抽两包烟、沉迷于色情和酒精的人。尽管如此，他还是吸引了特蕾莎的注意，两人在第一次见面后的三天内就结婚了。切特毫不掩饰他不喜欢特蕾莎孩子的事实。他们也不太喜欢他。唯一的例外是苏珊·诺尔，特蕾莎的第三个孩子。10岁的苏珊极其聪明，是一个贪婪的读者，她与切特建立了特殊的联系，切特与她讨论
politics and mythology. Years of beatings had made Susan reserved and frightened, but with Chet, she found an adult she could confide in. Their closeness angered Teresa, who was overcome with bitter jealousy whenever Chet showered Susan with attention. Her resentment towards her husband continued to fester as time went by. What bothered Teresa most was Chet's fascination with the witchcraft and the occult. While these practices were against her own religious beliefs, Teresa drew issue with how Chet's interest in them had rubbed off on her daughter, Susan. Less than three months into their marriage, Teresa filed for divorce. The departure of Chet Harris in November 1976 did
政治和神话。多年的殴打使苏珊变得内向和恐惧，但与切特在一起，她找到了一个可以倾诉的成年人。他们的亲密关系激怒了特蕾莎，每当切特对苏珊表现出关注时，她就会被苦涩的嫉妒所淹没。随着时间的推移，她对丈夫的怨恨不断加深。最让特蕾莎困扰的是切特对巫术和神秘学的迷恋。虽然这些做法违背了她自己的宗教信仰，但特蕾莎对切特的兴趣如何影响了她的女儿苏珊感到不满。结婚不到三个月，特蕾莎就提出了离婚。1976年11月切特·哈里斯的离开
little to ease the tensions escalating in Teresa's household. By this point, Teresa petrified her children. She slapped them if they came home even a minute after curfew. If they talked back, they were hit with a plank of wood Teresa called the Board of Education. She even ordered her children to punish one another, with the younger boys made to hold down the girls so that eldest son Howard could beat them. Teresa herself became a recluse and refused to let anyone but her children into their house. She gained weight and barely bathed or changed her clothes. In the brief moments where she was thinking clearly, she would try to make amends for her behavior by treating her children to trips and treats. But these moments were rare.
并没有减轻特蕾莎家中不断升级的紧张局势。到这个时候，特蕾莎让她的孩子们感到恐惧。如果他们回家晚了一分钟，她就会打他们。如果他们顶嘴，他们就会被特蕾莎称为“教育委员会”的木板击打。她甚至命令孩子们互相惩罚，让年幼的男孩按住女孩，以便长子霍华德可以殴打她们。特蕾莎自己变得隐居，拒绝让除了孩子以外的任何人进入他们的房子。她体重增加，几乎不洗澡或换衣服。在短暂的清醒时刻，她会试图通过带孩子们去旅行和买零食来弥补自己的行为。但这些时刻很少见。
Despite having ended their marriage, Teresa's mind often wandered back to Chet Harris, who she now believed was a demon sent to her by another one of her former husbands, Robert Nor Senior, who she claimed also practiced witchcraft. She would rant about him to her children. While the older kids largely ignored her, their younger siblings were terrified by her delusions and listened intently. Teresa never got over Susan's connection to Chet, and when she found out that they were meeting up behind her back, Teresa was furious. She pulled Susan out of school so she could keep an eye on her at all times. Life at home with her mother became especially hard for Susan when Teresa started accusing her
尽管结束了婚姻，特蕾莎的思绪经常回到切特·哈里斯身上，她现在认为他是另一个前夫罗伯特·诺尔高级派来的恶魔，她声称他也练习巫术。她会向孩子们抱怨他。虽然大一点的孩子大多不理会她，但年幼的弟妹们被她的妄想吓坏了，并仔细聆听。特蕾莎从未放下苏珊与切特的联系，当她发现他们背着她见面时，特蕾莎大发雷霆。她让苏珊退学，以便随时监视她。当特蕾莎开始指责苏珊
of being a witch. At 15 years old, Susan tried running away but was quickly detained and temporarily placed in a receiving home. She begged not to be sent back home, likening her life there to a concentration camp. After a number of meetings with Teresa, in which she was given the all-clear as a competent parent, Susan was returned to her custody. Teresa assured counselors that her daughter's stories were all lies and she would be safe. When they got home, Teresa instructed all of her children to punch Susan in the stomach. If they didn't do it hard enough, they had to punch her again. From then on, Teresa kept Susan handcuffed to her bed at night,
是一个女巫时，苏珊在家与母亲的生活变得格外艰难。15岁时，苏珊试图逃跑，但很快被拘留并暂时安置在一个收容所。她恳求不要被送回家，将那里的生活比作集中营。在与特蕾莎进行了几次会面后，她被认定为一名合格的家长，苏珊被送回了她的监护之下。特蕾莎向辅导员保证，她女儿的故事全是谎言，她会很安全。当他们回到家时，特蕾莎指示所有的孩子殴打苏珊的肚子。如果他们打得不够重，他们就必须再打她一次。从那时起，特蕾莎晚上把苏珊铐在床上，
worried she would sneak out to perform witchcraft on her if she wasn't restrained. Susan was also kept sedated with medications her mother had stolen during her time as a hospice worker years earlier. During meals, she was tied to a chair and often left there for hours at a time. The constant abuse took its toll on Susan, who began mumbling nonsensical statements that only cemented her mother's belief that she was a witch or that a demon had entered her body. Among the many reasons Teresa had grown to resent Susan was her slim figure and teenage youthfulness. One day, she accused the demon of taking fat off of Susan's body and putting it on her own. In turn, she began force-feeding Susan to make
担心如果她不被束缚，她会溜出去对她施展巫术。苏珊还被喂食了她母亲多年前在临终关怀中心工作时偷来的药物。在用餐时，她被绑在椅子上，经常一坐就是几个小时。持续的虐待对苏珊造成了伤害，她开始喃喃自语一些毫无意义的话，这只会加深她母亲认为她是女巫或恶魔进入了她身体的信念。特蕾莎开始怨恨苏珊的众多原因之一是她苗条的身材和青春活力。有一天，她指责恶魔从苏珊的身体上拿走脂肪并放在自己身上。反过来，她开始强迫苏珊进食以使
her gain weight. Teresa pushed the spoon into Susan's closed mouth with such force, it chipped her front upper tooth. Sometime in 1981, 15-year-old Susan was walking down the hallway when Teresa cornered her. She screamed into her daughter's stomach, asking the demon why she had put on more weight. Certain that Susan was making her fat and ugly on purpose, Teresa ordered her son Robert to restrain his older sister. He did as he was told and pushed Susan into the bathroom when they were suddenly interrupted by the ear-splitting crack of a gunshot. Susan clutched the left side of her chest and fell backwards into the bathtub. The gun-wielding Teresa snapped out of her murderous
她增重。特蕾莎用力将勺子塞进苏珊紧闭的嘴里，导致她的一颗上门牙崩裂。1981年的某一天，15岁的苏珊正走在走廊上，特蕾莎把她逼到了角落。她对着女儿的肚子尖叫，问恶魔为什么她又长胖了。确信苏珊是故意让她变胖变丑，特蕾莎命令她的儿子罗伯特按住他的姐姐。他照做了，把苏珊推进了浴室，这时他们突然被一声震耳欲聋的枪响打断了。苏珊捂住左胸，向后倒进浴缸。持枪的特蕾莎从杀人般的
rage and rushed to her injured daughter. She pushed her finger into the bleeding hole in Susan's chest and felt the bullet lodged in her back just below her left shoulder blade. In an uncharacteristic moment of tenderness, she said, I'm so sorry. A stunned Susan replied, I forgive you, you know I love you. Susan Norr was left in the bathtub for a month. While the bullet remained in her back, the wound itself healed and she made a miraculous recovery. The near-death experience didn't prompt any change in Teresa, who was still convinced that Susan was possessed by a demon. She moved her family to an apartment in North Sacramento where Susan's ordeal continued. From her early teens, Susan had
愤怒中清醒过来，冲向受伤的女儿。她把手指伸进苏珊胸口流血的洞里，感觉到子弹卡在左肩胛骨下方的背部。在一次罕见的温柔时刻，她说：“我很抱歉。”震惊的苏珊回答说：“我原谅你，你知道我爱你。”苏珊·诺尔在浴缸里待了一个月。虽然子弹仍留在她的背部，但伤口本身愈合了，她奇迹般地康复了。这次濒死体验并没有促使特蕾莎有任何改变，她仍然确信苏珊被恶魔附身了。她把家人搬到了北萨克拉门托的一间公寓里，苏珊的磨难还在继续。从十几岁起，苏珊就
been forced by her mother to engage in sex work to support the family and all of her earnings were taken by Teresa the moment she returned home. Despite this, Susan found herself enjoying the work as it enabled her to leave the house. Her brothers didn't share the same concerns. Teresa still afforded them more freedom than their female siblings, allowing them to deal cannabis and take on small jobs. Still, they were also forced to hand over their pay to their mother. When Susan was home, she was handcuffed to the dining table and forced to sleep on a blanket on the floor. With no appetite, her weight plummeted. Teresa would kick her as she walked past. Then, in July 1984, Teresa grasped a pair of scissors like a dart and threw them into Susan's back.
被迫从事性工作来养家糊口，她所有的收入在回到家时都被特蕾莎拿走了。尽管如此，苏珊发现自己很享受这份工作，因为它使她能够离开家。她的兄弟们没有同样的担忧。特蕾莎仍然给予他们比女性姐妹更多的自由，允许他们贩卖大麻并从事小工作。尽管如此，他们也被迫将工资交给母亲。当苏珊在家时，她被铐在餐桌上，被迫睡在地板上的毯子上。由于没有食欲，她的体重急剧下降。特蕾莎走过她身边时会踢她。然后，在1984年7月，特蕾莎像抓飞镖一样抓起一把剪刀，扔进了苏珊的背部。
The blades pierced Susan's skin, but she was so emotionally detached at this point that she didn't even flinch. Although Teresa said Susan provoked her, the incident led to a compassionate shift in her behavior. Susan noticed the change and saw it as an opportunity. Hours later, mother and daughter were sitting together on a sofa in the lounge. Teresa had been drinking alcohol and smoking cannabis and was in the best mood she had been in for weeks. Susan plucked up the courage and asked for a one-way ticket to Alaska to start a new life, explaining that Teresa would never see or hear from her again. Susan waited nervously as her mother considered the proposition.
刀片刺入了苏珊的皮肤，但此时的她情感已经极其麻木，甚至连眉头都没有皱一下。尽管特蕾莎声称是苏珊激怒了她，但这件事却让她的行为发生了某种带有“同情心”的转变。苏珊注意到了这种变化，并将其视为一个机会。几小时后，母女俩坐在休息室的沙发上。特蕾莎喝了酒，抽了大麻，心情是几周以来最好的。苏珊鼓起勇气，请求一张去阿拉斯加的单程票，想去开始新的生活，并解释说特蕾莎以后永远不会再见到她或听到她的消息。苏珊紧张地等待着，母亲正在考虑这个提议。
She then said the words Susan had been longing to hear. Yes, she would let her go to Alaska on one condition. Teresa retrieved a bottle of antipsychotic medication she had pocketed from her old job and gave a handful of capsules to Susan, who washed them down with a quart of whiskey. Susan then lay face down on a blanket in the dining room and passed out within a few minutes. Teresa checked she was unconscious before commencing the operation. The only way she would allow Susan to leave was if the bullet lodged in her back was removed. That way there would be no evidence of her abuse if Susan ever decided to speak of it.
随后，她说出了苏珊渴望听到的话。是的，她会让她去阿拉斯加，但有一个条件。特蕾莎拿出一瓶她从旧工作中顺手牵羊带回来的抗精神病药物，抓了一把胶囊给苏珊，苏珊就着一夸脱威士忌把药吞了下去。接着，苏珊脸朝下趴在餐厅的地毯上，几分钟内就失去了知觉。特蕾莎确认她昏迷后，开始了手术。她允许苏珊离开的唯一条件，就是取出她背部残留的子弹。这样一来，如果苏珊以后决定说出真相，就不会有她虐待的证据了。
Susan's younger brother Robert, who was 15 at the time, performed the surgery under Teresa's orders. He cut into the skin and muscle just under Susan's left shoulder blade with an exacto knife and spotted the bullet. Sticking his fingers deep into the wound, Robert pried it out and was surprised by the lack of blood. His mother stated it was because a demon had possessed Susan's body and made her undead. Susan woke from the procedure a day later and it was immediately clear something was very wrong. She alternated between groggily murmuring and screaming in pain. Teresa pumped her full of antibiotics and painkillers, but soon Susan was overcome with fever. She began hallucinating and spoke of watching her life as a movie before her eyes.
苏珊当时15岁的弟弟罗伯特在特蕾莎的命令下进行了手术。他用一把美工刀切开苏珊左肩胛骨下方的皮肤和肌肉，找到了那颗子弹。罗伯特将手指深深探入伤口，把子弹撬了出来，并对伤口几乎没有流血感到惊讶。他母亲声称这是因为恶魔附身了苏珊的身体，使她变成了不死之身。苏珊在手术一天后醒来，很明显情况非常糟糕。她时而昏昏沉沉地喃喃自语，时而痛苦地尖叫。特蕾莎给她灌了大量的抗生素和止痛药，但苏珊很快就陷入了高烧。她开始产生幻觉，说自己像看电影一样看着自己的一生在眼前闪过。
When Susan's eyes yellowed from jaundice and the skin on her back turned black, Teresa claimed it was the devil revealing itself and refused to take her to a hospital. She made Susan wear infant diapers when she could no longer go to the bathroom. Sheila and Terry kept vigil at their ailing sister's side as she deteriorated on the floor. Every time Susan went still and silent, Terry gently shook her awake to make sure she was still alive. Susan would babble at her incoherently in response. Then one day, Teresa told her other children, we've got to get rid of Susan. She's going to die on us. We're going to have to kill her. On July 16, 1984, she collected all the photographs she had of Susan and burned them in the backyard.
当苏珊的眼睛因黄疸变黄，背部的皮肤变黑时，特蕾莎声称这是魔鬼在显形，并拒绝送她去医院。当苏珊无法再去洗手间时，她强迫苏珊穿上婴儿尿布。希拉和特里守在病重的姐姐身边，看着她在地板上日渐衰弱。每当苏珊变得静止无声时，特里就会轻轻摇醒她，以确保她还活着。苏珊会语无伦次地回应她。后来有一天，特蕾莎告诉其他孩子：“我们得除掉苏珊。她快要死在我们手里了。我们必须杀了她。”1984年7月16日，她收集了所有苏珊的照片，并在后院烧掉了。
Then she waited for nightfall. As midnight approached, Teresa drove down interstate 80 with sons William and Robert, who were forced to accompany her. The boys sat in the back seat with the unconscious and bound Susan sandwiched between them. Inside the trunk of the car were Susan's belongings, including clothes, jewellery and books. The diapers she had been wearing were bagged up as well. Upon reaching the secluded Squire Creek area, Teresa stopped the car and had William and Robert retrieve Susan. The pair were horrified, but did not dare disobey their mother. They laid Susan on a blanket with her possessions. 16-year-old William zipped up her hooded sweater, concerned that his older sister might get cold. Teresa then ordered Robert to get
然后她等待夜幕降临。午夜临近时，特蕾莎开车沿着80号州际公路行驶，车上带着被迫随行的儿子威廉和罗伯特。男孩们坐在后座，昏迷且被捆绑的苏珊被夹在他们中间。汽车后备箱里装着苏珊的私人物品，包括衣服、珠宝和书籍。她穿过的尿布也被装进了袋子里。到达偏僻的斯奎尔溪地区后，特蕾莎停下车，让威廉和罗伯特把苏珊抬出来。两人感到恐惧，但不敢违抗母亲。他们把苏珊和她的财物放在一条毯子上。16岁的威廉拉上了她连帽衫的拉链，担心姐姐会着凉。随后，特蕾莎命令罗伯特从后备箱里拿
a tank of gasoline from the trunk of the car, pour it over Susan and set her alight. The trio drove home in silence, until a bird smacked into the windshield. Teresa screamed in fright, turned to William and Robert and said, that bird was a sacrifice. God thinks we did a good thing. Upon returning home, Teresa ordered her eldest daughter, Sheila, to scrub the floor where Susan had spent her final days. Like her younger sister, Sheila had endured a heavily controlled life at the hands of her mother. Aside from running the odd errand, she was kept at the family home and less forced into sex work to line her up with her mother. She was then taken to the hospital and
出一桶汽油，倒在苏珊身上并点火。三人沉默着开车回家，直到一只鸟撞上了挡风玻璃。特蕾莎惊恐地尖叫起来，转向威廉和罗伯特说：“那只鸟是祭品。上帝认为我们做了一件好事。”回到家后，特蕾莎命令大女儿希拉擦洗苏珊度过最后时光的地板。和妹妹一样，希拉在母亲的控制下过着极其压抑的生活。除了偶尔跑跑腿，她被关在家里，甚至被迫从事性工作来填补母亲的腰包。她随后被带到医院，
home and less forced into sex work to line her mother's pockets. With Susan gone, Sheila was terrified that she would become her mother's next target. It wouldn't be long before her fears were realized. In the winter of 1984, 19-year-old Sheila Sanders was riding her bike to pick up a pack of cigarettes for her mother when she was hit by a car. After recovering from her minor injuries, Sheila felt a noticeable shift within her family. Teresa had told her other children that Sheila had died and a demon had taken over her body. Suddenly, Sheila found herself cowering from an increase in beatings. When Teresa was convinced she had caught a sexually transmitted disease from Sheila
并被迫从事性工作来填补母亲的腰包。苏珊死后，希拉非常害怕自己会成为母亲的下一个目标。没过多久，她的恐惧就变成了现实。1984年冬天，19岁的希拉·桑德斯骑自行车去为母亲买烟时被车撞了。在轻伤康复后，希拉感觉到家里发生了明显的变化。特蕾莎告诉其他孩子，希拉已经死了，一个恶魔占据了她的身体。突然间，希拉发现自己因为遭受越来越多的殴打而蜷缩在角落里。当特蕾莎确信自己和希拉共用同一个马桶座圈而染上了性病后，
after the pair shared the same toilet seat, she punished her daughter by handcuffing her to the dining table. History was repeating itself, though instead of Susan being force-fed, it was Sheila. It was Sheila. As detailed in the book Whatever Mother Says, Sheila once confided in her mother that she was depressed. Teresa retrieved her gun and handed it to her daughter, remarking, if you're so depressed, then kill yourself. With a shaking hand, Sheila placed the barrel to her temple and squeezed the trigger. There was a gentle click. The gun wasn't loaded. On a hot day in June 1985, Sheila snapped. After being slapped by her mother for refusing to eat, she retaliated by kicking Teresa in the leg. A furious Teresa screamed that her shin was broken,
她惩罚女儿的方式是将她铐在餐桌上。历史在重演，只不过这次被强行喂食的不是苏珊，而是希拉。正如书中所述，希拉曾向母亲吐露自己很抑郁。特蕾莎拿出枪递给女儿，说道：“如果你这么抑郁，那就自杀吧。”希拉颤抖着手，将枪口对准太阳穴，扣动了扳机。只听“咔哒”一声。枪里没有子弹。1985年6月一个炎热的日子，希拉崩溃了。在因拒绝进食被母亲扇耳光后，她踢了特蕾莎的腿作为反击。愤怒的特蕾莎尖叫着说她的胫骨断了，
then fell quiet. Later that night, she called on her sons, William and Robert. Teresa ordered them to restrain Sheila and lock her in the linen closet. Struggling with all her might, Sheila was no match for her burly brothers. Once trapped inside the two-by-four foot space, she pleaded to be let out. Teresa stuffed towels against the door to muffle her daughter's cries and turned up the television. The neighbors didn't hear a thing. Days later, Teresa made a rare trip out to the store. Her sons were at work, leaving 14-year-old Terri alone in the house with the imprisoned Sheila.
然后安静了下来。那天晚上晚些时候，她叫来了儿子威廉和罗伯特。特蕾莎命令他们制服希拉，并将她锁在亚麻布储藏室里。希拉拼尽全力挣扎，但根本不是强壮的兄弟们的对手。一旦被困在那个两英尺乘四英尺的空间里，她就哀求着被放出来。特蕾莎用毛巾塞住门缝以掩盖女儿的哭声，并调大了电视音量。邻居们什么也没听到。几天后，特蕾莎难得地去了一趟商店。她的儿子们都在上班，留下14岁的特里独自在家看守被囚禁的希拉。
Taking her chance to help her sister, Terri opened the linen closet door, causing Sheila to fall out onto her side. With her hands restrained behind her back and wearing nothing but underpants and socks, Sheila was drenched in sweat and pleaded for a drink. Forbidden by her mother to give Sheila food or water, Terri retrieved a beer and held the liquid to her sister's lips. Then she heard the sound of a car door slam. Mother was home. Against Sheila's protests, Terri pushed her back into the stifling hot closet and shut the door.
特里抓住机会想帮助姐姐，她打开了储藏室的门，希拉侧身倒了出来。希拉双手被反绑在身后，只穿着内裤和袜子，浑身湿透，哀求着要喝水。由于母亲禁止给希拉提供食物或水，特里拿了一瓶啤酒，将液体送到姐姐嘴边。这时，她听到了关车门的声音。母亲回来了。不顾希拉的抗议，特里把她推回了闷热的储藏室并关上了门。
While the decision to do so would haunt Terri for life, she understood that it was either shut the door or wind up in the closet with Sheila. Terri later heard a hallucinating Sheila say, There is a light above me. I think it's a hole. I'm going to climb towards it. A series of thumps followed. Then everything went quiet. Teresa ignored her daughter's body in the closet for three days. Then on June 24, 1985, she was compelled to act when the smell of decomposition began to permeate through the apartment. Teresa donned some rubber gloves, sat on her bed, and carefully picked off every
虽然这个决定将困扰特里一生，但她明白，要么关上门，要么自己也会被关进储藏室和希拉在一起。特里后来听到产生幻觉的希拉说：“我头顶有一道光。我想那是个洞。我要爬向它。”接着是一连串的撞击声。然后一切都安静了。特蕾莎无视储藏室里女儿的尸体整整三天。直到1985年6月24日，当腐烂的气味开始弥漫整个公寓时，她才被迫采取行动。特蕾莎戴上橡胶手套，坐在床上，仔细地挑出她能在粉色枕套上看到的每一根
hair she could see on a set of pink pillowcases. She then lined the inside of a cardboard box with the pillowcases before ordering William and Robert to retrieve Sheila's body. Sheila was placed into the cardboard box, which was then loaded into the trunk of Teresa's car. For the second time in their life, Robert and William were tasked with helping dispose of one of their sister's bodies. Terri was forced to stay behind and clean up. As she scrubbed away at the dark fowl liquids that had seeped into the closet floor, Terri's mind raced. As the last remaining daughter, would she be the next to die? That night, Teresa watched as William and Robert dug a grave for Sheila outside the town of Truckee. All of a sudden, a police cruiser pulled up behind
头发。然后，她在纸箱内衬上枕套，命令威廉和罗伯特取出希拉的尸体。希拉被放进纸箱，随后被装进特蕾莎汽车的后备箱。罗伯特和威廉一生中第二次被指派协助处理姐姐的尸体。特里被迫留下来清理现场。当她擦洗渗入储藏室地板的深色恶臭液体时，特里的脑海中思绪万千。作为最后一个幸存的女儿，她会是下一个死者吗？那天晚上，特蕾莎看着威廉和罗伯特在特拉基镇外为希拉挖了一个坟墓。突然，一辆警车停在他们身后。
them. William was certain they had been caught and was relieved to think that their nightmare would finally be over. By pure chance, neither officer picked up on what was going on and soon left. Teresa's luck continued when Sheila's body was found. Authorities incorrectly linked her murder to Herbert Boyle, the killer of Gail Smith. At this point, both Sheila and Susan had been named Jane Does, as their isolated life ensured no one could identify their remains. As far as Teresa was concerned, she had gotten away with everything. Just after 3am on September 29, 1986, 16-year-old Terri Noor emptied three cans of lighter fluid throughout her family's North Sacramento apartment. Checking once more that her escape
威廉确信他们被抓住了，想到噩梦终于要结束，他感到一阵解脱。纯属巧合，两名警察都没有察觉到发生了什么，很快就离开了。当希拉的尸体被发现时，特蕾莎的运气还在继续。当局错误地将她的谋杀案与盖尔·史密斯的杀手赫伯特·博伊尔联系在一起。此时，希拉和苏珊都被命名为“简·多伊”（无名氏），因为她们与世隔绝的生活确保没有人能辨认出她们的遗骸。在特蕾莎看来，她已经逃脱了所有罪责。1986年9月29日凌晨3点刚过，16岁的特里·诺尔在家里位于北萨克拉门托的公寓里倒了三罐打火机油。再次确认她的逃生
path was clear, she lit a match. With shaking hands, she slowly lowered it to the floor. The fire took hold much quicker than Terri anticipated. She leapt out a window, just as flames began climbing the walls. While running from the scene, Terri passed several fire engines on their way to tackle the inferno. She reached a hotel room, where her mother was waiting. The fire had been Teresa's idea. She had grown paranoid over a lasting stain in the linen closet, fearing it would link her to Sheila's murder. She had convinced Terri to start the blaze, promising her only remaining daughter that she could move out if she went through with it.
路线畅通后，她划了一根火柴。她颤抖着手，慢慢地将其降到地板上。火势蔓延的速度比特里预想的要快得多。就在火焰开始爬上墙壁时，她跳出了窗户。在逃离现场时，特里经过了几辆赶往火场的消防车。她到达了一家酒店房间，母亲正在那里等着。这场火灾是特蕾莎的主意。她对亚麻布储藏室里留下的永久性污渍变得疑神疑鬼，担心这会把她和希拉的谋杀案联系起来。她劝说特里纵火，并向她唯一的女儿承诺，如果她照做，就可以搬出去住。
Terri accepted the offer. As her sons had since left her of their own accord, Teresa relocated to Salt Lake City in Utah, where she underwent a complete makeover. She became a Mormon and kept herself well presented with expensive clothes and makeup. She also cut her long dark hair and began sporting a blonde wig. With the remainder of her children either literally or metaphorically dead to her, it was time for Teresa to start a new life. Susan Noor and Sheila Sanders were the only two of Teresa's six children to be murdered, yet the remaining four, Howard, William, Robert and Terri, would struggle from the
特里接受了提议。由于儿子们已经自愿离开，特蕾莎搬到了犹他州的盐湖城，在那里她进行了彻底的改头换面。她成为了摩门教徒，穿着昂贵的衣服，化着精致的妆容，保持着良好的形象。她还剪掉了长长的黑发，开始戴上金色假发。随着剩下的孩子们在现实或心理上都已与她断绝关系，特蕾莎是时候开始新生活了。苏珊·诺尔和希拉·桑德斯是特蕾莎六个孩子中仅有的两名被谋杀的孩子，但剩下的四个孩子——霍华德、威廉、罗伯特和特里，余生都将挣扎于
abuses they had endured at her hands for the rest of their lives. Eldest Howard Sanders was the first to leave home and did so before the murders took place. One day, Howard read a newspaper article about the Jane Doe found burned to death at Squire Creek. Certain it was his sister Susan, he asked his mother where she was. Teresa said Susan had run away and claimed Sheila had too. Although Howard didn't believe her, he feared she would kill him as well, so he didn't press the matter. Over the years Howard struggled to hold down work for addiction had several run-ins with the law and his marriage ended in divorce. At 17, William Noor was the next to move out,
他们所遭受的虐待中。长子霍华德·桑德斯是第一个离家出走的人，他在谋杀案发生前就离开了。一天，霍华德读到一篇关于在斯奎尔溪发现被烧死的“简·多伊”的报纸文章。他确信那是他的妹妹苏珊，便问母亲她在哪。特蕾莎说苏珊离家出走了，并声称希拉也是。虽然霍华德不相信她，但他担心母亲也会杀了他，所以没有追问。多年来，霍华德因成瘾问题难以维持工作，多次与法律发生冲突，婚姻也以离婚告终。17岁时，威廉·诺尔是下一个搬出去的人，
leaving between the murders of Susan and Sheila. He was summoned back home to help with disposing of Sheila's body and did so out of fear of his mother. Drugs and alcohol dulled the recurring nightmares William experienced, enough to help him maintain a marriage and job. Despite his troubles, he was a friendly and amiable man working hard to get his life on track. In the book Mother's Day by Dennis McDougal, William reflected on his family, saying, I never wanted to see any of them again. When I left, I was like, I'm out. I was out and I was staying out. Robert Noor remained living with his mother until her move to Salt Lake City, where he left her soon after. Like his brothers, he sought reprieve from his childhood memories
他在苏珊和希拉的谋杀案之间离开。他被召回家协助处理希拉的尸体，出于对母亲的恐惧，他照做了。毒品和酒精缓解了威廉反复出现的噩梦，足以帮助他维持婚姻和工作。尽管生活坎坷，但他是一个友好且和蔼的人，努力让生活重回正轨。在丹尼斯·麦克杜格尔所著的《母亲节》一书中，威廉回顾了自己的家庭，说道：“我再也不想见到他们中的任何一个。当我离开时，我就想，我走了。我离开了，而且我会一直待在外面。”罗伯特·诺尔一直和母亲住在一起，直到她搬到盐湖城，之后不久他也离开了她。像他的兄弟们一样，他寻求从童年的记忆中解脱，
through the use of drugs and alcohol. After a string of arrests, he was jailed for burglary and took the opportunity to earn his high school equivalency diploma to expand his employment prospects upon his release. However, his newfound freedom didn't last long. 22-year-old Robert was sentenced to a further 15 years in prison for the second-degree murder of a bartender shot dead during a robbery. He narrowly avoided a murder conviction and the death penalty by cutting a deal with the prosecution to testify against his co-accused. Theresa kept her word with youngest daughter, Terry. After she had started the fire that consumed their North Sacramento apartment, Terry was finally free to live her own life. Her experiences
通过使用毒品和酒精。在多次被捕后，他因入室盗窃入狱，并利用这个机会获得了高中同等学历，以增加出狱后的就业前景。然而，他新获得的自由并没有持续多久。22岁的罗伯特因在抢劫过程中枪杀一名酒保，被判二级谋杀罪，入狱15年。他通过与检方达成协议，指控共同被告，从而勉强避免了谋杀定罪和死刑。特蕾莎对小女儿特里信守了承诺。在纵火烧毁北萨克拉门托的公寓后，特里终于可以自由地过自己的生活了。她此后的经历
from then onwards mirrored those of her siblings. Adding to her turmoil was the discovery that she was unlikely to conceive the children she desperately wanted due to the severe beatings she suffered throughout her youth. Terry had also endured childhood sexual abuse. In 1993, her oldest brother Howard admitted to authorities that he had molested Terry when she was six and he was 13. Howard faced no repercussions for these actions. Over the years, Terry confided in friends about her childhood, including the murders of her sisters. Few believed her, and those that did encouraged her to speak to police, who ultimately dismissed her story as far-fetched. On one occasion, a sheriff took interest in
反映了她兄弟姐妹的遭遇。更让她痛苦的是，她发现由于青少年时期遭受的严重殴打，她很可能无法怀上她渴望的孩子。特里还遭受过童年性虐待。1993年，她的大哥霍华德向当局承认，他在特里6岁、他13岁时猥亵过她。霍华德没有因这些行为受到任何惩罚。多年来，特里向朋友们倾诉了她的童年，包括她姐妹们的谋杀案。很少有人相信她，而那些相信的人则鼓励她去报警，但警方最终认为她的故事太离谱而将其驳回。有一次，一位警长对
Terry's allegations and interviewed her. A detective was then assigned to investigate whether any unsolved homicides could be linked to Theresa Norr. He concluded there were none, and Terry was once again brushed off. More than once, Terry tried to end her pain by taking her own life. Then one night, her outlook changed. In the last week of October 1993, 23-year-old Terry Norr sat on a sofa blinking back tears. She had just had an argument with her husband, who accused her of lying once again about her sister's murders. Terry's attention was drawn to the television screen before her, where a suited man spoke solemnly towards the camera. It was John Walsh, the host of America's
特里的指控产生了兴趣并采访了她。随后，一名侦探被指派调查是否有任何未破的凶杀案可以与特蕾莎·诺尔联系起来。他得出的结论是并没有，特里再次被拒之门外。特里不止一次试图通过自杀来结束痛苦。然后有一天，她的前景改变了。1993年10月的最后一周，23岁的特里·诺尔坐在沙发上，强忍着泪水。她刚刚和丈夫吵了一架，丈夫再次指责她关于姐妹谋杀案的谎言。特里的注意力被面前的电视屏幕吸引，一个穿着西装的男人正对着镜头庄重地说话。那是约翰·沃尔什，美国《
Most Wanted. The series reported on unsolved crimes or wanted fugitives, while requesting viewers to offer their tips and insights via a toll-free phone number. Terry watched intently and made a decision. She grabbed for the telephone and dialed the show's tip line. A woman on the other line listened as Terry revisited the story of her sister's murders. To her disappointment, Terry was told there was nothing the show could do for her. Exhausted by the lack of help and support from all ends, Terry broke down sobbing. Yet, unlike others, the woman who answered the call didn't dismiss Terry entirely. She suggested that Terry contact the county authorities where the murders took place.
头号通缉犯》节目的主持人。该系列节目报道未破案件或通缉逃犯，同时请求观众通过免费电话提供线索和见解。特里全神贯注地看着，做出了一个决定。她抓起电话，拨打了节目的举报热线。电话那头的女人听着特里重述她姐妹被谋杀的故事。令她失望的是，特里被告知节目组帮不了她。由于各方都缺乏帮助和支持，特里崩溃大哭。然而，与其他人不同的是，接听电话的女人并没有完全打发特里。她建议特里联系谋杀案发生的县当局。
Sergeant John Fitzgerald at the Placer County Sheriff's Substation in Tahoe City took Terry's call. While detailing Susan's murder, Terry referenced an antique wedding ring her sister had been wearing when set alight at Squire Creek. Sergeant Fitzgerald's interest was already peaked, but the ring mention really drew his attention. Shaking with emotion, Terry explained how no one believed her story about her mother, not even her husband. Sergeant Fitzgerald responded, young lady, if it's any consolation to you, you can tell your husband this. I found a 17-year-old female burning near Squire Creek on July 17, 1984. I believe she was your sister.
太浩市普莱瑟县警长分局的约翰·菲茨杰拉德警官接听了特里的电话。在详细描述苏珊的谋杀案时，特里提到了她姐姐在斯奎尔溪被点火时戴的一枚古董结婚戒指。菲茨杰拉德警官的兴趣已经被激发，但戒指的提及真正引起了他的注意。特里情绪激动地颤抖着解释说，没有人相信她关于母亲的故事，甚至连她的丈夫也不信。菲茨杰拉德警官回答说：“年轻女士，如果这能给你一点安慰，你可以告诉你丈夫这一点。1984年7月17日，我在斯奎尔溪附近发现了一名被烧死的17岁女性。我相信她就是你的姐姐。”
10 days after Terry's call, Sergeant John Fitzgerald arrived on the doorstep of a modest, low-set home in East Salt Lake City. An older lady named Mrs. Cross answered the door. She was the living carer for the home's owner, an elderly woman named Alice Sullivan. Sergeant Fitzgerald looked at the photograph in his hands of Theresa Nor, then eyed the haggard and pale woman standing before him. She invited them inside. The search for Theresa Nor had not been an easy one, as she had gone by many surnames throughout her life. Mrs. Cross was initially reluctant to admit to anything, but eventually revealed that she was going by her maiden name. Her actual name was Theresa Nor.
在特里打完电话10天后，约翰·菲茨杰拉德警官抵达了东盐湖城一栋简朴的低层住宅门口。一位名叫克罗斯夫人的年长女士开了门。她是这栋房子主人——一位名叫爱丽丝·沙利文的老妇人的生活护理员。菲茨杰拉德警官看着手中特蕾莎·诺尔的照片，然后打量着站在他面前憔悴苍白的女人。她邀请他们进去。寻找特蕾莎·诺尔并不容易，因为她一生中用过许多姓氏。克罗斯夫人起初不愿承认任何事情，但最终透露她使用的是婚前姓氏。她的真名是特蕾莎·诺尔。
Theresa remained calm when shown the warrant for her arrest. Theresa then contacted Alice's son and informed him that she was being arrested. Knowing his mother's nurse is nothing but a kind-hearted and generous individual, he was stunned at the news and asked why. Theresa said she didn't know. When it came time to take Theresa Nor into custody, Sergeant Fitzgerald found her trying to escape via a rear door of the house. I feel like a sacrificial lamb being led to the slaughter, she told him. Investigators soon arrived at Theresa's former North Sacramento apartment. Luckily for them, the arson Terry committed years prior didn't do as much damage as Theresa had hoped. Once inside, officers came across a small closet in the hallway.
当被出示逮捕令时，特蕾莎保持冷静。特蕾莎随后联系了爱丽丝的儿子，通知他自己被捕了。得知母亲的护士是一个心地善良、慷慨大方的人，他感到震惊，并询问原因。特蕾莎说她不知道。当需要将特蕾莎·诺尔拘留时，菲茨杰拉德警官发现她正试图从房子的后门逃跑。“我觉得自己像是一只被送去屠宰的替罪羊，”她告诉他。调查人员很快抵达了特蕾莎以前在北萨克拉门托的公寓。幸运的是，特里多年前纵的火并没有造成特蕾莎所希望的那么大的破坏。进入公寓后，警官们在走廊里发现了一个小储藏室。
Sergeant Fitzgerald's stomach churned. According to Terry, Sheila had been locked inside the closet, but the door in front of him didn't have a lock. Sergeant Fitzgerald began to worry. Had Terry lied to him, he phoned her to clarify. As detailed in the book Whatever Mother Says, Terry explained, it's the smaller closet just outside the bathroom. This closet had been spotted by investigators, but they had dismissed it as the one used to imprison Sheila as they couldn't imagine anyone being kept inside such a small space. Staining found in this closet came back positive for human blood.
菲茨杰拉德警官感到胃里一阵翻腾。据特里说，希拉曾被锁在这个储藏室里，但他面前的门上没有锁。菲茨杰拉德警官开始担心。特里是在对他撒谎吗？他打电话给她澄清。正如《无论母亲说什么》一书中所述，特里解释说：“是浴室外面那个较小的储藏室。”这个储藏室之前已被调查人员发现，但他们认为它不是用来囚禁希拉的，因为他们无法想象有人会被关在这么小的空间里。在这个储藏室中发现的污渍经检测呈人类血液阳性。
Meanwhile, police had arrived at William Nor's workplace in Sacramento and placed him under arrest. Robert Nor, who was already in prison, was also charged in relation to his sister's murders. The Placer County Sheriff told the Sacramento B newspaper that the case was one of the most bizarre and unbelievably sad family situations anyone could ever imagine. Why someone would do something this vicious is beyond comprehension, and when it's your own mother and brothers, it's almost unbelievable. As the horror of what Theresa Nor had done to her own children came to light, those who knew her as Theresa Cross were left in shock.
与此同时，警方抵达了威廉·诺尔在萨克拉门托的工作地点并将他逮捕。已经在监狱里的罗伯特·诺尔也因其姐妹的谋杀案受到指控。普莱瑟县警长告诉《萨克拉门托蜜蜂报》，这是任何人能想象到的最离奇、最令人难以置信的悲惨家庭状况之一。为什么有人会做出如此恶毒的事情令人无法理解，而当凶手是你自己的母亲和兄弟时，这几乎令人难以置信。随着特蕾莎·诺尔对自己孩子所做暴行的曝光，那些认识她为“特蕾莎·克罗斯”的人感到震惊。
They couldn't marry up the two personalities of the one woman, the sadistic and jealous murderer, versus the compassionate and gentle nurse's aide. Some believed detectives had made a mistake and arrested the wrong person. Others thought she was taking the fall for her son's actions. Even those who suspected something was odd about the family never imagined the truth was far more heinous. A former neighbor told the Sacramento B, I knew those people were weird, but I didn't know how weird. It's just wild. It scares me, and it makes me leery of making friends.
他们无法将同一个女人的两种人格联系起来：残忍、嫉妒的杀人犯，与富有同情心、温柔的护士助理。有些人认为侦探犯了错误，抓错了人。另一些人认为她在为儿子的行为背黑锅。即使是那些怀疑这个家庭有些古怪的人，也从未想到真相竟然如此令人发指。一位前邻居告诉《萨克拉门托蜜蜂报》：“我知道那些人很奇怪，但我不知道有多奇怪。这太疯狂了。它让我害怕，让我对交朋友感到谨慎。”
Theresa Nor was charged with two counts of murder, two counts of conspiracy to commit murder, and two special circumstances charges, multiple murder and murder by torture. When speaking of Theresa's sons, prosecutor John O'Mara made an extraordinary plea for mercy. He said that all of Theresa's children had been subjected to a family situation that not even Stephen King could imagine, and agreed that their role in the murders was mitigated by the abuse they'd suffered at the hands of their mother. Elder's son Howard told the Fresno Bee, I want people to understand that it's not my brother's fault. They were children at the time, and she had total control over them. She was crazy,
特蕾莎·诺尔被控两项谋杀罪、两项共谋谋杀罪，以及两项特殊情况指控：多重谋杀和酷刑谋杀。在谈到特蕾莎的儿子们时，检察官约翰·奥马拉提出了非同寻常的减刑请求。他说，特蕾莎所有的孩子都经历了一种连斯蒂芬·金都无法想象的家庭状况，并同意他们在谋杀案中的角色因他们从母亲那里遭受的虐待而减轻。长子霍华德告诉《弗雷斯诺蜜蜂报》：“我希望人们明白，这不是我兄弟的错。他们当时还是孩子，她完全控制了他们。她疯了，
but she was the adult. As part of a plea deal, Robert Nor agreed to testify against his mother in return for a reduced charge of being an accessory after the fact. He was sentenced to three years to be served concurrently with his sentence for the fatal armed robbery. The serious charges against William Nor were also dropped, with his attorney stating that his client was raised in a cage and tortured by the zookeeper. William received a three-year suspended sentence, was placed on five-year probation, and ordered to continue therapy he had been receiving for post-traumatic stress disorder. He said he bore no animosity towards his mother, and when asked what he believed
但她是成年人。”作为认罪协议的一部分，罗伯特·诺尔同意指控他的母亲，以换取减轻为事后从犯的指控。他被判处三年监禁，与他因致命武装抢劫罪所服的刑期同时执行。针对威廉·诺尔的严重指控也被撤销，他的律师称他的当事人是在笼子里长大的，并受到饲养员的折磨。威廉被判处三年缓刑，五年缓刑期，并被命令继续接受他因创伤后应激障碍而一直在进行的治疗。他说他对母亲没有任何敌意，当被问及他认为
should be her sentence, William replied, Whatever the court decides is fine. Three mental health professionals examined Theresa Nor to establish whether she was competent to stand trial. While it couldn't be ascertained what exact mental health issues Theresa faced when she murdered Susan and Sheila, her remaining children agreed that she suffered from paranoia and delusions. Howard remembered an episode when he was 14, where Theresa disappeared for four days straight. Upon her return, she spoke of having found some pennies. She had thrown them away, but then they turned back up at the motel where she was staying. She said that no matter what she did with the pennies, they kept reappearing.
她应该受到什么惩罚时，威廉回答说：“法院决定什么就是什么。”三名心理健康专家对特蕾莎·诺尔进行了评估，以确定她是否有能力受审。虽然无法确定特蕾莎在谋杀苏珊和希拉时面临的具体心理健康问题，但她剩下的孩子们一致认为她患有偏执狂和妄想症。霍华德记得他14岁时发生的一件事，当时特蕾莎连续失踪了四天。回来后，她谈到自己捡到了一些便士。她把它们扔掉了，但后来它们又出现在她住的汽车旅馆里。她说，无论她怎么处理这些便士，它们都会不断出现。
Howard later remarked, I didn't understand it at the time, but looking back on it, I mean, obviously, they were paranoid delusions. The children learned to anticipate these episodes as they often occurred after Theresa had consumed a lot of alcohol. When drunk, she was also known to have explosive angry outbursts, prompting her children to hide from her when they saw a drink in her hand. Reports suggest that having her mother die in her arms from a heart attack when she was 12 might have triggered Theresa's lifelong mental health problems. Yet, sadistic and violent behavior seemed to run in her family. Her half-brother had a history of
霍华德后来评论道：“我当时不明白，但回想起来，我的意思是，显然，那是偏执妄想。”孩子们学会了预见这些发作，因为它们通常发生在特蕾莎喝了很多酒之后。据了解，她喝醉时会有爆发性的愤怒，这促使孩子们看到她手里拿着酒杯时就会躲起来。有报道称，12岁时母亲因心脏病发作死在怀里，可能触发了特蕾莎终身的心理健康问题。然而，残忍和暴力行为似乎在她的家族中遗传。她同母异父的兄弟有
cruelty to animals, violent assault, burglary, and armed robbery. This behavior culminated in a double homicide so brutal that knife markings were left in the wooden floor underneath the two victims. The professionals examining Theresa reached different conclusions. Two believed she was faking mental illness, while the other felt she was suffering from multiple personality disorder. The report prepared for the judge slanted towards the majority opinion. It read, When Theresa was asked about the two daughters she is accused of murdering, her reaction betrayed a preposterous and transparent attempt to feign mental illness. As a result, Theresa was ruled competent to stand trial. The presiding judge said,
虐待动物、暴力袭击、入室盗窃和武装抢劫的前科。这种行为最终导致了一起极其残忍的双重凶杀案，两名受害者下方的木地板上甚至留下了刀痕。检查特蕾莎的专家们得出了不同的结论。两人认为她在伪装精神疾病，而另一人认为她患有多重人格障碍。为法官准备的报告倾向于多数人的意见。报告写道：“当特蕾莎被问及她被指控谋杀的两个女儿时，她的反应暴露了她试图伪装精神疾病的荒谬和透明的企图。”因此，特蕾莎被裁定有能力受审。主审法官说，
Any defendant capable of such a performance would also be able to work with their attorney in preparing a rational defense. By her attempt to Malinga, I believe Theresa has rather clearly revealed that she understands precisely what is going on. When she found out that her son was going to testify against her, Theresa changed her plea. When asked by the judge if she was pleading guilty because she was in fact guilty, Theresa hesitated and then replied, I believe I would be found guilty. In return for Theresa's cooperation, the prosecution requested she be spared the death penalty. A more than likely sentence should the case go to trial. A booming voice then shouted,
“任何有能力进行这种表演的被告，也能够与他们的律师合作准备合理的辩护。通过她试图装病的行为，我相信特蕾莎已经相当清楚地表明她完全了解正在发生的事情。”当她发现儿子要出庭指控她时，特蕾莎改变了认罪态度。当法官问她是否因为确实有罪而认罪时，特蕾莎犹豫了一下，然后回答说：“我相信我会被判有罪。”作为特蕾莎配合的回报，检方请求免除她的死刑。如果案件进入审判，这很可能是判决结果。这时，一个洪亮的声音喊道：
No, in the courtroom. It was Robert Norcenia, the father of Susan, Robert, William and Terry. He yelled to his ex-wife, I hope you burn in hell for what you did to my kids. Outside, Robert Sr. told a reporter for the Sacramento Bee that Theresa should fry, adding, My daughter is in her grave and will be there forever. Why should she be allowed to live out the rest of her life? Theresa was sentenced in October 1995. A victim impact statement written by her son Robert Norcenia was read out to the courtroom. It read in part, My mother cruelly and calculatingly tortured her victims both physically and mentally over the course of years, killing them in every way possible over and over again.
“不！”在法庭上。那是苏珊、罗伯特、威廉和特里的父亲罗伯特·诺尔塞尼亚。他对着前妻大喊：“我希望你为你对我孩子们做的事在地狱里燃烧。”在法庭外，罗伯特老先生告诉《萨克拉门托蜜蜂报》的记者，特蕾莎应该被处死，并补充说：“我的女儿在坟墓里，将永远在那里。为什么她应该被允许度过余生？”特蕾莎于1995年10月被判刑。法庭上宣读了她儿子罗伯特·诺尔塞尼亚撰写的受害者影响陈述。部分内容写道：“我的母亲多年来残忍且蓄意地在身体和精神上折磨她的受害者，以各种可能的方式一遍又一遍地杀死她们。
We have all been sentenced to life without parole, reliving our own private nightmares in the early hours, imprisoned in our memories. Theresa's attorney made an impassioned plea for concurrent sentences. He argued that she, quote, never had a fair chance in life. She was raising these kids as best she could when she was still a child herself. The prosecutor snapped back, saying that Theresa's crimes were unspeakable and detailed the profound effect her actions had on her surviving children, quote. She's saddled them with so much emotional baggage they are never going to come out of this hole. In summing up, the presiding judge described Theresa's actions as callousness beyond belief. He sentenced her to two consecutive life
我们都被判处终身监禁且不得假释，在清晨重温我们自己的私人噩梦，被囚禁在我们的记忆中。”特蕾莎的律师为合并执行刑期进行了激情的辩护。他辩称她“在生活中从未得到过公平的机会。她在自己还是个孩子的时候就尽其所能抚养这些孩子。”检察官反驳说，特蕾莎的罪行令人发指，并详细说明了她的行为对幸存子女造成的深远影响，称：“她给他们背上了太多的情感包袱，他们永远无法走出这个深渊。”在总结陈词中，主审法官形容特蕾莎的行为是“令人难以置信的冷酷”。他判处她两项连续的终身
sentences. Theresa shook in her seat as her outcome was revealed. An attempt at parole in 2019 failed. Her case will be reviewed again in 2024, when Theresa will be in her late 70s. Following the revelation that her mother's carer was a killer, Alice Sullivan's daughter began clearing out the spare room the woman she knew as Mrs. Cross had occupied. She came across a number of carefully wrapped presents Theresa was planning on handing out at Christmas. As detailed in Whatever Mother Says, she said, It was so sad. I took them down to the basement close to tears. I still cannot believe that a good person like Theresa could be responsible for the crimes she is accused of. In hindsight, it's possible Theresa's children would have been
监禁。当判决结果公布时，特蕾莎在座位上颤抖。2019年的一次假释尝试失败了。她的案件将在2024年再次审查，届时特蕾莎将年近70岁。在得知母亲的护理员是一名杀人犯后，爱丽丝·沙利文的女儿开始清理那个她所知的“克罗斯夫人”曾居住过的空房间。她发现了许多特蕾莎计划在圣诞节分发的精心包装的礼物。正如《无论母亲说什么》中所述，她说：“这太令人难过了。我带着泪水把它们拿到地下室。我仍然无法相信像特蕾莎这样一个好人竟然会对她被指控的罪行负责。”事后看来，如果特蕾莎在1964年因枪杀第一任丈夫克利福德·桑德斯而被定罪，她的孩子们可能
spared their horrific ordeal had she been convicted for the shooting murder of her first husband, Clifford Sanders, in 1964. Prosecutor at the trial, District Attorney Donald Dorfman, was certain he had a solid case against Theresa and was stunned when she was acquitted. He feared the jury would be fooled by the young, pregnant and seemingly innocent woman before them, and pleaded with them to find her guilty so she could not go on to harm anyone else. He told them, Not every murderer looks like the witch in Snow White. It would be easier if they did. Following the positive identifications of the Squire Creek and Martyrs Creek campground Jane Does, their unmarked graves were updated. The first now features the name Susan Noor,
会免于那场可怕的磨难。审判时的检察官、地方检察官唐纳德·多夫曼确信他对特蕾莎有确凿的证据，当她被判无罪时，他感到震惊。他担心陪审团会被她面前那个年轻、怀孕且看似无辜的女人所欺骗，并恳求他们判她有罪，这样她就不会继续伤害任何人。他告诉他们：“并非每个杀人犯看起来都像《白雪公主》里的女巫。如果他们是那样的话，事情会简单得多。”在对斯奎尔溪和烈士溪露营地的“简·多伊”进行积极辨认后，她们的无名坟墓得到了更新。第一个现在刻有苏珊·诺尔的名字，
with an image of a book underneath a tree paying homage to Susan's love of reading. The second carries the name Sheila Sanders alongside a blossoming flower. Beloved sister is written above the message. May you now find peace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
树下有一幅书的图像，以向苏珊对阅读的热爱致敬。第二个刻着希拉·桑德斯的名字，旁边是一朵盛开的花。在信息上方写着“挚爱的姐妹”。愿你现在找到安宁。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。